right i mean it's just i'm constantly
proud of her right even like having a
kid riley i was just like holy [ __ ] you
did it you're a mom like survived just a
beautiful healthy boy
action
how did that go not good
tell me what c-section there's nothing
about that oh my god so they cut you
open while you're awake why not and then
they pull out all your guts and insides
and then they pass your baby megan
is it because
my vagine was broken no it's not broken
oh is it because your [ __ ] is tight it
is tight yeah the canal i was told today
it was tight yeah so you have to you
have tight canal i have tight canals
that's good um but he was also
relaxed ryan that's all he was sideways
all right
so i couldn't push them out even if i
tried oh really so what are they they
cut a little thing in like a little and
then they're down there oh my god
they're like don't worry your bikini
line your bikini will i'm like i don't
want them like bikinis but yeah i get i
got a scar right here and it goes across
all my stretch marks so it's gorgeous
and they pull out all my guts and then
they pull out the baby then they put all
my guts back in
and then they sew it back up and you're
awake and i didn't know if i would hear
anything or feel anything you're numb
but it's like getting your your teeth
worked on so i was like you could feel
the pressure they actually sometimes oh
god you can hear it and smell your skin
burn yeah it's gross whoa your skin's
burning for a reason
i've never like broken a bone and never
had stitches this was tough for me
really yeah but i don't numb it they
numb you yeah they put a big needle in
your back yeah and then it numbs from
like boobs down
why can't they work around the organs i
don't know man but yeah sweetie i don't
think you have full understanding maybe
it's under the order listen i have a
full understanding of the human anatomy
yeah okay so what i'm saying is is that
you have your large intestines correct
i bet you for if you were a doctor you
cut from the back
it's probably easier
maybe somebody hasn't thought about that
right maybe work around the spine
all right so
you have to pull it all out is what
you're saying okay so you can't
delicately but it can't just feel
delicate it's it's in a it's seven
minutes though yeah seven minutes of
like cutting you getting the baby out
um and then it's 45 minutes of vacuum
suck put everything back in oh my god
and the recovery for c-sections is a lot
harder than um a vaginal no [ __ ] yeah
because they opened you up well like a
lot of people sliced yeah they slice you
my god and so they stuck it in back in
but see i didn't have contractions
that's why people are like c-sections
are easy and i'm like no it's not yeah i
thought it was just like book your
appointment you go in and out boom baby
it felt like that but then after you're
like i thought it was like
it happened
you never saw the movies where like it's
three in the morning and then the
husband has to ferociously drive to them
yeah we didn't have to go through
anything but like we did like friday at
noon it was like ordering pizza we're
like
wow
that was nice that was nice not guessing
it was nice so the baby comes out they
sew you up they put the intestines back
in and then you're looking at your baby
now did they put it oh because he went
to the nicu
so he went to like a club
great club like yeah a place for when
babies need help
so he wasn't like waking up like he
wasn't crying and i was like what the
[ __ ] and i was just laying there and the
doctor was like daddy you should go with
a baby and i was like don't leave me and
they're like you should go and he left
which it's okay and so i laid there for
45 minutes just like
surrender surrender surrender while they
sewed me back together again
you didn't think you were gonna die
though right no i didn't think i was
gonna die i was just like hope my kid's
alive because this sucks
so when you went to when you went to the
uh with the baby
did you fall in love
it was a mini him so yeah look just like
him a little redhead
is it the most beautiful experience
you've ever written yeah
i mean that experience was scary
oh when he wouldn't open his eyes and
stuff yeah no
crying but nothing was coming out so
it's like
all the movies
yeah no crap
it also [ __ ] i would be freaking the
[ __ ] dude i was like why isn't he
crying that was my thought and
yeah he was smiling imagine me there
babe
ah you wouldn't last i don't think you'd
even last the procedure they even asked
the husband like do you want to see i
think i would still look at my insides
you know well our favorite show is my
600 pound life me too it's our favorite
we have so much in common
i watch it and then i go to the gym yeah
that's the only thing i get we watch it
and we make love feast yeah oh i don't
there's something very i'm sorry oh i
was scratching my genitals i'm sorry
that it was the wrong timing
yeah i didn't like it so i apologize
our first christmas together i got him a
framed picture of doctor now yeah he
does all the barriers
yeah yes and [ __ ] him i think but he
can't even watch any of the surgeries i
can't watch it oh i can't imagine you
would be able to watch anything in real
life
but i've seen your vagina before up
close and personal imagine this
if another dude's coming out of it i
think i'll be able to handle it why is
the whole dude i've seen that too i've
seen my aunt give birth twice no so i
was ready to push and then they were
like nah he's sideways when your aunt
was giving birth how old were you i was
14 years old and you're in the room yep
i was like what are you doing in there
she's like i have to see that i went in
to say hi and then the contraction
started again and they forgot about me
and then i became so like into it and
involved that i was holding her leg like
ten nine like counting oh wow
the miracle of life they him yeah i was
crying and i was like this is barren
rye
little man yeah
what's up
i'm chill
chill yeah it's called the miracle of
life
you better get with it i i'm with it i'm
with it after holding him for the first
time i was like i gotta get my [ __ ]
together and it wasn't even my kid it's
like my nephew he's my nephew yeah is
there a love there there's a love for
sure i see him every day and i'm like
immediately him like yeah so much i wish
i had an uncle like him he's a cool
uncle you don't have good uncles they're
not as monstrous as him
but i'm a little aggressive in this i
know but you walked in and there was
yeah you missed this am i that he said i
had sexual energy and i i just walked
he's like you're a man man stand up take
a bow get up yeah yeah
take a spin boom
oh you're a big he's a big boy yeah he's
a guy he's your type
is that your dog yeah he's my big baby
boy right here
why it's uncomfortable why do i don't
want to do that with a guest no you did
i didn't i apologize i don't want to do
that with you my hair stylist he's like
oh i get a tackle baby boy i love you
he's like he knows yeah baby boy yeah
and i i mean i'm straight but i'm okay
with any kind of affection i think i'm
very vain maybe i don't know i love any
kind of
love and affection attention good and i
love giving it great
so ryan i want to say this okay yeah i
met a guy the other night
and don't say it to me well because i
didn't know really much about him but
tatum
oh my god channing tatum tanning tatum
yeah he says who is tatum channing
i said that for like three years i was
doing it i met him it's hard i met the
he's gorgeous and he pounded me mm-hmm
oh [ __ ] yeah dude
and when i did this it was like this
like this is his fist clothes oh he's a
big boy right and he available